[Applause]
and the Oscar goes
too it's a clean sweep the Lord of the
Rings The Return of the King oh this is
just unbelievable and I'm
so honored touched and relieved that the
academy and the members of The Academy
that has supported us have have seen
past the trolls and the Wizards and the
hobbits and uh recognizing fantasy this
year fantasy is an F-word that hopefully
the 5-second delay won't do anything
with um I just want to say a very few
quick words uh especially to the people
of New Zealand and the government of New
Zealand and the city councils and
everybody who's supported us the length
the length and breadth of the country
Billy Crystal is welcome to come and
make a film in New Zealand anytime he
wants a special thanks to Peter Nelson
and Ken camons who were with me right
from the days of bad taste to meet the
feebles which were which were wisely
overlooked by the academy